-Yes, Penn, welcome, welcome,
welcome to the show.
Thank you for coming on.
-Thank you for having me.
-You look like a stud.
You look good, bud.
-That is 90% of my job.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like it.
Thom Browne?
-Yes, it is.
-Yeah.
I haven't seen you since
I think you had a baby boy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was gonna say
it's been 15 years.
He is not 15 years old.
He's 2 1/2.
-2 1/2.
-Yeah.
-How's fatherhood going?
-Well, you know,
he's a pandemic kid.
So that is --
Anybody who has kids,
it's a joy.
It's an immense --
I mean, it's wild.
It's lovely. It's great.
It's a challenge.
Shout-out to all the parents.
-Wow.
-Keep going.
-Yeah, keep going.
-It gets better.
-Yeah, does he know
that Daddy plays a serial killer
on television?
-We're gonna have to
break that one to him.
No, you know, there was recently
a day where I was like --
I was doing something
really sweet with him,
you know, like, in my lap.
And then I sat on the remote.
And, like, you wouldn't think
this would --
It just went right to Netflix
on the TV.
And my face was right on the TV.
And he was like, "Daddy!"
And I started to race around
because the next thing
he was gonna see --
-Was something crazy.
-Something really crazy.
So I was like...
And I got it off.
-Yeah, you're like,
"Put on 'Bluey.'
Put on 'Bluey.'
'Bluey,' 'Bluey.'"
-"Siri, Siri, Siri!"
-"Siri, Siri, put on --"
Sorry. No, yeah.
By the way, can I say
how great you are on TikTok?
-Thank you.
-You went on --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're crushing it.
Right now I think you have
over 180 million views
on only 10 --
Higher? Yeah.
Only 10 posts.
-That sounds crazy to me, yes.
That's -- That's like --
-That's a lot of views.
-That's over a tenth
of a billion, isn't it?
-It is.
-Isn't it?
-Yeah, of course.
-It's nearly 2/10,
which is nearly 1/5.
And if we could round it up --
-Almost 3/10.
-It's like a quarter.
-It's like you're doing
half a billion views.
-It's like half a --
-What made you like TikTok?
What made you get into --
'Cause I would assume
maybe you go to Instagram.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean, for me,
social media became a place of
a lot of anxiety over the years.
I started to use it
less and less and less.
-Yeah.
-And then, you know, I was
waiting for the right moment,
thinking maybe
I'll start a TikTok.
Like, I wasn't sure.
I was on the fence.
And then Taylor Swift
came out with her record.
And --
-Yeah.
"Anti-Hero" was the big one.
And my podcast co-host
is a huge Swiftie,
like, a huge Swiftie.
Shout-out to Nava.
She, like --
So we -- we made this --
this "Anti-Hero" thing,
this video thing.
-Just 'cause
Taylor inspired you.
-Yeah, for fun.
And then when we made it,
we were like,
"I think that's the one
that I get on TikTok with."
So, you know.
-Yeah.
And then you did another one
with Meghan Trainor
"Made You Look" dance.
-Only pop stars.
That's basically --
-It shows --
I mean, you do enjoy dancing.
When I think of you,
I think of singing and dancing.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
I do like to sing.
I actually love to sing
and I love to dance.
Music is my first passion
by far.
But I do not like
to mix them together.
Because usually
that's a musical.
And I don't like musicals.
-That's not your thing.
But I do want to show a clip
of this "Made You Look" thing.
It's very funny.
Here's Penn Badgley. Watch this.
-♪ I made you look ♪
♪ Yeah, I look good
in my Versace dress ♪
♪ But I'm hotter when
my morning hair's a mess ♪
♪ But even with my hoodie on ♪
♪ Bet I made you look ♪
♪ I made you look ♪
-I mean, come on!
I would -- I love that.
-Yeah, it's fun.
It's fun. It is fun.
-Bryan Cranston was just on
the show, and we were talking.
And I heard this story
that you auditioned once
for "Breaking Bad."
-Yeah, actually, I mean, now
that it's become a little bit
of a topic of public interest,
I'm like, I mean, I'm --
So I went out
for "Breaking Bad."
And in my memory, Aaron and I
were testing against one another
for the role of Jesse.
And, you know, that's great.
Like, Aaron so --
He killed that role.
Like, it was obviously his.
And that year --
or the years prior,
we'd been going out for things
together.
-You went out for the same role?
-Yeah.
Like, you know, when you're
coming up in Hollywood,
you test for things.
You know what this is like.
-I never made that it far
to test for something.
But, yeah, I auditioned.
I auditioned for things, yeah.
"Hi, Penn." You're like,
"Get out of my face, loser."
And I go, "Alright."
-Yeah, but this was like --
It was the best script for
television that I'd ever read.
And actually, after
I didn't get it, I thought,
"Alright, great, that's fine,
but I don't know
if I can do any more TV."
Like, that was the one.
-Really?
-And I've been working
for nearly 20 years since
in television.
-Exactly, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're crushing it with "You."
We're gonna talk about
Season 4 right now.
All episodes available
right now on Netflix.
You don't want to give too much
away on the show and spoilers.
-I can't, yeah.
-But can we say kind of
what's going on in Season 4?
-I mean, honestly, if you watch
the trailers, they --
-They give a lot away.
-They do give so much away.
So basically, Joe is a --
He's a serial killer.
Right? You guys know that.
-Yeah.
-He puts people in a glass box.
-Yeah, but he's not --
-But this season,
he's trying not to.
He's -- He's --
[ Cheering ]
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We love him now.
He's a great guy.
-Yes, and he's trying
not to kill people.
And then in the first episode,
a dead body shows up.
That's not a spoiler.
-Yeah.
But here's the sp--
Can I say the spoiler?
-Yeah.
-I don't know if he's the one
who killed this person.
-Well, that's -- that is --
-Someone else --
There's a actual --
There's other killers.
-That's not a spoiler at all.
-There's other killers --
-Again, you said less
than what's in the trailer.
[ Laughter ]
-I did, right?
-You said far less.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-If you watch
the part two trailer,
it's gonna ruin part one.
Don't watch
the part two trailer...
-Just get into it.
-...if you want to see part one.
I posted it
and then took it off.
It's like -- I don't know.
Netflix knows what they're
doing, but it makes me nervous.
-No, yeah, just watch it
all the way through.
You'll be addicted to it.
It's so --
You're so good in it.
Congratulations on all the kudos
you've been getting for it.
-Thank you.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Penn Badgley
in Season 4 of "You."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cellphone buzzes ]
[ Suspenseful music playing ]
-"Hello again."
It's you.
[ Cellphone buzzes ]
"Nice jacket.
Brown's your color."
You could be anywhere.
Where are you, you sneaky?
"I'm learning a lot about you.
Paranoid.
Loner by nature."
You're a stalker,
wherever you are.
[ Cellphone buzzes ]
"Absolutely not
a real professor."
Oh, yeah?
Well, who are you?
Think. Think.
"Your name isn't Jonathan Moore.
I'll figure you out
soon enough."
I can't let you do that.
So I have to
figure you out first.
-Come on. That's --
That's good acting right there.
-There's not --
Not a single --
Not a single line was uttered.
If you notice,
I didn't say a word.
-That's what's called acting
right there.
-Acting is real.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Yes.
-Penn Badgley, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"You" on Netflix.
Check it out.
Maya Hawke performs
after the break.
Stick around, everyone.
Come on back.